I've heard tales of your kind which
you're a mutant created by magic
roaming the continent we don't want your
kind here hunting monsters for a price I
thought you'd have fangs or horns or
something
I had them filed down
[Music]
people call you a monster too
why not kill them because that I am what
they say I have all of our choices draw
our destinies closer
he's out there there's still hope
fine Carol two for me
judge me they say witches can't feel
human emotion what do you believe him
[Music]
bless
Reiter
it's all a saver
consistory Lee
the old destiny
my hunger tank temps
if you dismiss it
unleash
fool calamity upon us all
I'll take that chance
[Music]
welcome back everyone its charlie we
finally have the full official trailer
for The Witcher so we'll break it down
there's a whole bunch of book stuff
going on during this a lot of Easter
eggs if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I will be doing videos for the series
when it drops they finally confirmed the
official release date it's pretty much
exactly when we all thought it was going
to happen the week before Christmas so
we will be talking about all kinds of
Witcher stuff at the end of the year if
you're not familiar with the series or
you haven't read the books or played the
games don't worry but the games are
amazing the books are actually what the
series is going to cover the games are
meant to be a sequel story that pick up
after the events of the books but
starting with the footage the voiceover
you get at the beginning of the trailer
is yennefer talking to him talking about
I've heard about witchers I've heard
about all these mutations and the
potions that you take that's all
happening during this banquet scene
where all the different people are
trying to screw each other in the
background it's not the sorcerers
banquet from time of contempt that's one
of the later books season 1 is only
covering the short stories from the
first two books the last wish and sword
of Destiny this trailer is meant to be
the basic explainer for who Geralt of
Rivia is why he acts the way he does
what wishers do what his general
philosophy is like this later woman says
why don't you just kill all those
terrible people - he says because that
would make me the monster that they say
I am part of his code is that he only
kills monsters when they're a danger to
other people all these dead bodies at
the beginning of the trailer seem like
they're from the fall of sintra later
after nilfgaard comes back to invade on
the orders of Emperor Amir we'll be
talking about him a lot during the
series he's not the main villain but he
comes pretty close to being one of the
bigger villains then they do this thing
where they juxtapose Jennifer's purple
eyes with Geralt yellow cat eyes as he's
getting though Witcher potions and
undergoing his Witcher mutations that
grant him his special powers and long
lifespan yennefer also goes through some
transformations physical transformations
when she attains her power is a
sorceress this scene of Geralt during
the day walking into this fight seems
like it's from butcher of lavich and it
might seem like there are a ton of
different fights and battles going on in
the trailer but really it's just
different scenes from the same three to
four fights broken up into a bunch of
different parts this battle when he's
fighting the soldiers
seems like it's when he's helping Dooney
in pavetta earlier in the story Geralt
is brought to sintra by series
grandmother queen : the-- to oversee the
wedding of her daughter series mother
pavetta : the-- has all these suitors
and nobles from neighboring kingdoms
that's what these banquet scenes are for
but pavetta is really in love with a
cursed monster or a cursed human that
looks like a monster named unni he's the
one that looks like he has the head of a
hedgehog
no spoilers for dooney's secret identity
we'll talk about that later after the
series premieres there's a whole lot
going on here that we can't really talk
about without getting into spoilers but
all the trailers talk about people being
worse than monsters the wedding here is
an example of Queen : the-- in the
people of central in the nobles being
terrible people in karma is a [ __ ]
because after a Geralt manages to save
Dooney and prevent pavetta from being
forced to marry one of these other
suitors you see later in time nilfgaard
sax Sentra and Queen Clancy lays dying
yelling it's ciri to go seek out Geralt
for protection there's just an example
of karma coming back around on terrible
people like is it's terrible that
nilfgaard is invading and sacking sintra
but they themselves were just as
terrible to do knee in pavetta earlier
in the story we can't go too deep on why
nilfgaard is invading without getting
into spoilers so we'll talk about that
when the serious premieres but really
they're after ciri and nofe guard is
trying to consolidate power by
conquering all the neighboring kingdoms
so ciri is not the only thing that
they're after this is the school where
yennefer studied to be a sorceress then
there's the scene of her trying to make
it with Geralt at this banquet Geralt
riding into bladvic in taking the
witcher potions as the ennifer talks
about the story she's heard of witchers
and the mutations that they undergo we
get our first look at just skier with
Geralt and Roche riding down the road
this might be from the last wish the
last wish is really the first time the
geralt and yennefer meet but they may
change that a little bit for the books
the way she's talking to him here makes
it seem like it's the first time that
they've met but really it's earlier in
the story when they actually meet for
the first time so it's kind of hard to
tell based on the way they cut this
footage this is more of Geralt getting
ready to fight off ren freeze med and
blab accan this scene of the people in
the tavern treating him like crap is
just another example of how normal
people are generally mistrustful and
fearful of all
it's not just Geralt that they're afraid
of they just opposed this with Geralt
fighting monsters who kind of seemed
terrible then notice how they jump back
and forth between that and then the
scenes of regular people being even more
terrible in bladvic in in the tavern
like the monsters seem bad but it's
really humans who are terribad these are
scenes of him actually fighting Ren free
herself I did a whole video explaining
the meaning behind the name Geralt is
given the butcher of lavich and I'll
link that at the end of this but the
super quick version is is that Ren free
is coming to bladvic in to get revenge
against a sorcerer called Strega bor who
himself is a very terrible person and
who she has a lot of history with and
good reason to want to get revenge
against him but in order to do that she
threatens the lives of all these normal
townspeople who aren't doing anything in
bladvic and so Geralt is forced to kill
all of Ren freeze men to protect those
townspeople but at the end of it it gets
even worse for him because he fights all
these people off saves the townspeople
but the townspeople themselves treat him
like a monster because he looks like he
just butchered get it butcher oblivion
all these people so they started
throwing rocks at him so even the people
that he just saved from being
slaughtered or acting horribly towards
him
this giant battle scene just seems like
it's one of the major nilfgaardian wars
with sintra maybe the Battle of sodden
hill they're really two major Wars with
nilfgaard and sintra so this could be
either one this is yennefer and Geralt
on the road it might be during the last
wish earlier during their first meeting
from the books but like I said it's kind
of hard to tell how much they've changed
the timeline of the books this is just
Clancy dying telling ciri to find Geralt
because he'll protect her from the
nilfgaardian 'he's this scene of Geralt
on the castle bridge might be from
earlier at the beginning of pavetta
sweating this is ciri in the middle of
her escape from sintra there was a
longer version of this scene that they
screened last week at London Comic Con
where she runs into a boy and they sort
of give you some scenes with her that
let you know what her personality is
like before she winds up in the Forester
brothel on with the dryads but then
she's actually in bra : talking to the
dryads it's probably right before she
meets Geralt for the first time then
they have a whole bunch of scenes from
pavetta 's wedding when all [ __ ] breaks
loose and Geralt tries to save Dooney
from being slaughtered by everyone else
they the funny scene of him talking to
Roche don't judge me horse he calls all
of his horses row
he goes through several different horses
but they might just give him the one
brooch during season one this is just an
example of nilfgaardian soldiers being
terrible just to sell you on the idea
that they're coming for ciri like I said
there's no real main villain in The
Witcher series it just some people are
more terrible than others at times
there's a bunch of different scenes of
serious caping from Sentra and vesemir
trying to compel Geralt to save her
talking about destiny terrible things
will happen if you don't is they show
all these cataclysms and invasions in
the background ciri being his destiny so
to speak has made clear to him in wait
for it a book called sword of Destiny
see how they did that the scene of ciri
using her power is just meant to show
you how special she is and explain a
little bit about her elder blood they
might not get too deep into that during
the beginning of the series this scene
of the ground cracking in and around
sintra could be coming from Vilgax or
another sorcerer there are a lot of
sorcerers in The Witcher series and most
of them are terrible people
but ville de forts is the closest thing
to a main villain as you could say that
the series has but he's working with
nilfgaard and Emperor Amir when they
start to try and conquer all the
neighboring kingdoms then you get that
last voiceover from Geralt explaining
his philosophy evil is evil greater
lesser evil it's all the same
this here is friend Gila next to the
trebuchet during the invasion of Sentra
she's just another nilfgaardian
sorceress from the series this is
Jennifer in a different court after she
gets her powers and becomes a sorceress
she serves in a number of different
kingdoms before she meets Geralt for the
first time more of ciri on the run more
of Geralt fighting a different band of
marauders vesemir still yelling at
Geralt chasing him down talking about
destiny to help ciri this person before
we've seen it a lot of the trailers is
to saya she's one of the people that
takes in yennefer when she's younger and
trains her to become a sorceress
then there's a whole bunch of footage
from the comic-con scenes that they
showed up last week with yennefer and
queen Kahless of Leiria trying to save
her from an unknown sorcerer to this
trying to kill her in her baby
then this scene is more footage from the
end of the last trailer scene of Geralt
fighting that giant spider monster in
the swamps while he's all potion DUP the
spider monster is actually called a
kikah Moray they show up all over the
Witcher games there's a bunch of them
that live in swamps they have very human
looking heads but everybody let me know
in the comments if you spotted any
Easter eggs or anything big in the
trailer that I didn't mention
in the video when the series gets here
I'll find some cool Witcher themed
giveaway to do for all my videos so
leave all your suggestions in the
comments below but like I said they'll
probably be a couple more promos and
trailers that they'll drop before
premieres in December while you wait for
everything click here for my breakdown
of those other big Comic Con scenes and
learn why Geralt is called the butcher
of bladvic n' and click here for the
teaser for the brand-new Game of Thrones
prequel that they just announced
House of the Dragon about the Targaryen
family thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight